je voulais regarder un truc avec vous
j'ai trouvé ça super intéressant je sais
pas si vous l'avez vu elle est en train
de passer en télé en ce moment c'est la
nouvelle pub de Samsung qui est diffusé
alors je vois que là les sur le web
depuis déjà deux mois mais je l'ai vu il
y a pas longtemps en télé c'est la pub
qui parle du Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4
c'est le smartphone avec la paix de
Samsung et je trouve ça tellement malin
tellement bien fait que je voulais
absolument parler avec vous alors je
voulais tout de suite ce n'est pas du
tout une vidéo qui réalisait en
partenariat avec Samsung absolument pas
j'avais vraiment envie de vous le
montrer parce que dedans le boulot qui
est fait pour venir vous emmener sur des
concepts de marque vous montrer que
l'innovation du pliable c'est uniquement
Samsung et que Samsung la façon dont
c'est fait je trouvais ça tellement
malin que je voulais vraiment venir
cette faire cette analyse de de pub avec
vous vous allez voir franchement les
codes ce qu'ils ont employés dedans pour
venir faire passer tous ces messages
subliminaux ils sont absolument dingue
alors on va se faire ça ensemble et puis
avant c'est un petit générique allez on
y va
ok alors on y va la première chose à
faire la première toute première c'est
de regarder ensemble elle dure 30
secondes vous allez voir pas très
compliqué et je vous laisse à me dire ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire allez
on y va tu as pas encore vu mon nouveau
téléphone explique carrément
je changerai jamais pour Samsung j'aime
trop mon téléphone
sérieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est carrément vous voyez je l'aime mon
téléphone je changerai jamais pour ça
aussi
ok voyez bon ok donc là il vous passe le
message
et je trouve ça regardez ça dure 30
secondes mais je trouve ça hyper mal
alors je vous explique pourquoi et je
vous explique ce que je vois dedans et
comment je ressens le truc alors
effectivement la première chose ça
commence par un plan serré dans la poche
et on voit que le smartphone ne prend
pas de place sur d'une poche et hyper
discret déjà c'est le premier truc qui
veut le dire c'est à dire que on n'est
pas sur un espèce de voyez on n'est pas
sur un Galaxy Z flip 4 qui est beaucoup
plus gros donc on commence déjà à
montrer ok on est miniatures aisé c'est
autre chose un autre format donc là on
commence tu as pas encore vu mon nouveau
téléphone et là on a pas encore
introduit le concept de la marque mais
on commence à aller surtout un petit peu
généraliste tu as pas encore vu mon
nouveau téléphone donc ok elle le sort
elle le présente ça monte déjà c'est
marrant parce qu'il parle pas de
smartphone ici il parle de téléphone
alors qu'aujourd'hui on est plus en
train de se dire smartphone mais
pourquoi est-ce que le mot téléphone est
intéressant c'est parce que on vient
peut-être chercher une cible un peu plus
large et un petit peu moins technophile
d'ailleurs c'est une pub en télé même si
elle était là tu es sur le web donc on
va plus facilement parler un public qui
n'est pas averti avec qui on va venir
chercher des mots un peu plus très grand
public téléphone versus smartphone comme
ça tu as pas vu mon votre smartphone un
peu plus tes causes dès le départ donc
on va déjà qu'il y en a une qui est là
qui heureuse c'était un regard un peu
paumé elle est là j'en mets qu'est-ce
qui se passe et là il se plie carrément
alors cette phrase là elle est pas
anodine regardez on vient dessus
il se plie carrément je trouve ça
marrant parce que en fait une fois de
plus on s'adresse à des gens qui sont
pas forcément technophiles on va montrer
un nouveau téléphone et il se plie on
n'est pas juste regarde il se plie il se
plie carrément on vient asseoir le truc
en disant il y a un côté un peu magique
tu l'as pas tu connais pas je te montre
il se plie carrément d'ailleurs dans ce
sens-là il se plie pas il se déplie
c'était plus compliqué de dire il se
déplie carrément plutôt dire il se plie
carrément allez regarder continuer on
avance
et là en fait elle l'ouvre et on voit
qu'elle leur ferme donc en fait ce
qu'ils veulent montrer déjà c'est
l'action il s'ouvre dans un sens donc on
ouvre le truc et puis on leur ferme pour
le côté un petit peu waouh sur ce plan
qui est malgré tout un petit peu court
regardez tac il se referme et la musique
s'arrête en espèce de tension qui est là
genre oh et là tac le clap de fin est
donné et c'est là où le message est
intéressant et on rentre dans le dur
parce que on a la deuxième personne qui
elle par contre il prononce cette phrase
j'aime trop mon téléphone je changerai
jamais pour Samsung j'aime trop mon
téléphone regardez on reprend dès le
départ vous allez voir c'est dingue
et là ce qui est super marrant c'est que
la première personne à aucun moment elle
parle de Samsung elle dit elle le sort
de la poche tu as vu mon nouveau
téléphone il se plie carrément et elle
dit pas Samsung et l'autre elle parle de
Samsung elle voit Samsung elle sait que
c'est Samsung ça veut dire qu'elle
reconnaît le modèle ça veut dire que
c'est un modèle qui est déjà connu donc
déjà ça vient introduire le fait que
Samsung est une référence et que ce
modèle on le connaît même si elle
connaissait pas ce côté-là c'est Samsung
un nouveau téléphone c'est Samsung déjà
ça soit le truc et je trouve ça
extrêmement malin et ce qui est très
drôle c'est quand la personne dit
violet pour Samsung j'aime trop mon
téléphone je changerai jamais pour
Samsung j'aime trop mon téléphone donc
déjà il y a un truc on sent qu'elle est
en train d'asseoir un propos mais très
honnêtement quand elle le dit il est
évident qu'il n'y croit pas on voit
qu'il y a déjà un truc qui l'attendent
et qui a y croient pas et d'ailleurs
regardez le regard de la deuxième
j'aime trop mon téléphone
sérieux le petit blanc sérieux mais
c'est une évidence pour elle que on doit
changer on doit passer à Samsung donc le
truc est marrant et au-delà du truc qui
est marrant si vous voulez c'est que à
aucun moment on vient prononcer le nom
du modèle si vous regardez la pub en
entier on vient pas prononcer le nom du
modèle le nom du modèle est accouché
dehors c'est le Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4
quatrième génération enfin même si on
n'a pas vraiment eu quatre mais bon le
terme c'est 4 c'est fou parce qu'en fait
on vient pas une fois de plus asseoir le
le nom du modèle on vient vraiment dire
aujourd'hui les téléphones qui se plient
c'est Samsung pas les autres c'est que
Samsung et c'est ça qui est vachement
intéressant parce que en fait
aujourd'hui sur le marché européen
marché français il y a une seule marque
qui va toucher le grand public avec des
téléphones pliables c'est Samsung il y a
que même si on a vu d'autres marques
arriver même si on a vu effectivement
que Huawei avait effectivement des
téléphones impliable avec son Pocket et
tout mais non aujourd'hui le seul qui
fonctionne c'est Samsung même si on sait
que vous avez par exemple un Xiaomi là
avec son mix fold 2 même si eux ils sont
là avec un téléphone ce n'est jamais
qu'un produit qui ne sort pas en en
France même si effectivement au Nord
vient d'annoncer la sortie du Magic vs
un smartphone qui se plie un petit peu
comme celui de Xiaomi il sortira mais
l'année prochaine donc pour l'instant
Samsung alpha libre je trouve ça très
marrant parce qu'en fait comme il
travaille cette pub ils sont en train
d'asseoir la marque Samsung comme en
fait un peu la référence au niveau du
pliable très clairement c'est à dire que
la même manière que on va pas dire la
plupart du temps réfrigérateur on va
dire frigidaire frigidaire c'est une
marque et bien on pourrait se retrouver
à dire smartphone pliable tiens mon
Samsung et c'est ce qu'ils veulent faire
en fait ils viennent travailler la
marque surtout ils viennent la soirée en
disant aujourd'hui si vous voulez un
smartphone pliable il y a que Samsung et
d'ailleurs c'est dingue parce
qu'aujourd'hui une fois de plus je vous
le dis Samsung est le seul ça veut dire
que si vous voulez acheter un smartphone
qui se plie et celui-là il est très cool
de zip 4 il est juste hyper canon il en
vendent des sauts c'est des produits sur
les seuls à le vendre ils se gavent je
pense les produits où il y a de la marge
dessus donc c'est le produit sur
lesquels ils sont quand même
relativement plaisir et ils viennent
continuer d'asseoir ça il profite d'être
encore tout seul sur le marché pour dire
ok on va continuer d'asseoir que
l'innovation le smartphone qui se plie
c'est chez Samsung et il vous le redis
une fois de plus
sur mon téléphone Samsung versus
téléphone donc vous avez Samsung qui est
là qui est l'innovation ça se plie et en
face vous avez le téléphone un téléphone
lambda et c'est marrant parce que on
reprend vraiment le terme téléphone
depuis le départ tu as pas encore vu mon
nouveau téléphone il explique carrément
donc je trouve ça en fait fou ce message
là en 6 secondes vous avez tout vous
avez l'essentiel et je trouve ça
vraiment vraiment dans alors regardez on
va continuer à avancer donc là vous avez
sérieux et là vous avez tout le truc qui
est un peu schizophrénique ou la nana en
fait elle devient comme habiter le truc
elle l'a vu elle a eu un coup de cœur et
même si elle lutte on sent qu'elle est
obligée de l'acheter regardez lutte elle
est curieuse elle le voit partout dans
un bouquin donc on vous montre
effectivement ça s'ouvre comme un
bouquin donc on a aussi le fait qu'on
peut lire dessus alors avec un sandwich
ça va pousser un truc un peu loin mais
en fait elle voit ce téléphone partout
ça fait un peu film d'horreur vous voyez
la nana elle est vraiment habité par le
truc donc on voit les chaises qui se
plie le menu ayant fait elle voit le
smartphone partout et même la voyez elle
a encore les coups dans la tête
vous voyez la pizza
et l'appareil elle est chez sa
thérapeute le canapé se plie enfin bref
on voit que c'est un espèce de cauchemar
d'une certaine manière mais elle est
complètement habité par truc que je
changerai jamais pour ça me saoule comme
si elle était en train de tomber dans
les abysses du truc elle subissait et là
elle se réveille de son cauchemar et on
voit qu'en fait elle est complètement
habité par le truc elle en rêve elle en
fait des cauchemars et là elle prend son
téléphone genre oh là là je vais le
prendre je suis complètement habité il
ne le faut absolument voyez il y a le
côté un peu soulagement la tension se
libère et là elle arrive avec la petite
musique elle est au paradis
Joy the Flipside donc là l'introduit
quand même un peu le nom avec cet
anglicisme là puisqu'on se parle bien du
flip et pas du fold et là elle est bien
elle est détendue elle sourit elle a son
téléphone légèrement plié il est
toujours légèrement plié pour montrer
qu'ils puis effectivement et là c'est
très intéressant pourquoi regarder bien
il y a quelqu'un d'autre qui le voit ça
montre plusieurs choses ça montre deux
choses extrêmement intéressant la toute
première c'est qu'il y a un côté
contagieux avec ce produit c'est à dire
que c'est un produit qui est unique
c'est un produit qui est atypique c'est
un produit qui attrape les gens regardez
comme la personne elle vient vers le
produit donc en fait il y a une espèce
de contagion comme un pas faire un truc
avec un virus parce que je pense qu'on
en a assez souper du virus mais il y a
une vraie contagion on a envie et
surtout regardez il le regarde elle le
ferme et là et en fait c'est vraiment le
côté ouvert fermé qui tout de suite
attire et transforme le truc et surtout
le truc qui est génial regardez bien
là vous avez deux femmes vous avez une
troisième qui est à côté et encore une
je pense que c'est une femme qui qui
passe derrière donc on est vraiment et
derrière c'est encore je pense pas dire
de bêtises je pense encore une femme qui
passe derrière donc on est vraiment dans
un univers extrêmement féminin codifié
c'est un téléphone qui se destine plutôt
un public féminin et on le fait tout le
temps vous avez que des femmes regardez
ah si on a peut-être eu un homme
derrière qui est passé mais pas sûr et
là regardez vous n'avez que des femmes
partout là voilà mon sandwich là c'est
une femme assis dans le serveur j'ai
l'impression que c'est un homme et on ne
voit pas on doit être humain la main qui
me fait penser ça la thérapeute c'est
une femme qui n'en peux plus mais c'est
une thérapeute
voilà elle se réveille bon repas ce truc
on avance et là elle se retrouve dans le
bus et dans le bus vous avez quoi des
hommes derrière des hommes et à côté un
homme et ça c'est marrant parce qu'en
fait on part sur une cible féminine
qu'ensuite on vient chercher une cible
masculine et on voit qu'en fait la
contagion se propage pas que entre
femmes mais également entre tous les
genres on vient chercher un homme on
commence par la femme en disant regardez
il est tout petit il rentre dans ma
poche il est discret c'est un joli
accessoire en plus ils ont pris la
couleur mauve donc elle c'est bien le
Move qu'elle a à ce moment-là hop voilà
elle mauve elle elle a acheté le mauve
également alors qu'il existe plein de
couleurs ils ont plus d'édition be Spock
on peut venir personnaliser avec
créer l'envie et pour asseoir la marque
comme étant le pliable vous voulez un
pliable c'est Samsung que vous soyez une
femme que vous soyez un homme c'est
contagieux vous allez venir l'acheter et
je trouvais ça mais tellement fort
tellement malin en terme de message
publicitaire que je voulais absolument
vous en parler je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez comment est-ce que vous la
trouvez vous cette vidéo et je vous le
dis une fois de plus hein il y a
peut-être probablement encore des choses
qui m'ont échappé dans cette pub mais
tous les codes ils sont et même au
niveau du jeu d'acteur il y a un truc
qui est très très malin regardez la
personne qui l'a le téléphone elle est
sûre d'elle à aucun moment elle est pas
sûre d'elle elle par contre là juste en
face là qui n'a pas encore le Samsung on
sent que bon elle est pas trop en phase
avec elle-même on se dirait ce qu'elle
est pas réveillé on sent qu'il y a un
truc qui lui manque on sent qu'elle est
déséquilibrée dans sa vie il y a un truc
qui va pas alors que la deuxième qui a
déjà le téléphone soyons clair et les
carrés ça bouge pas on sent qu'elle est
structuré et qu'elle est épanouie
regardez comme elle a l'air heureuse et
l'autre elle a l'air mais tellement pas
bien et le moment où elle a le téléphone
il y a un vrai contraste également et là
elle devient bien vous voyez elle est
bien elle est sereine on la sent bien
dans son moment elle regarde son
téléphone on sent qu'elle est heureuse
et à contrario le mec qui en face vole
téléphone on le sent aussi un peu
désorienté et un peu perdu il y a tous
messages extrêmement rassurant par
rapport aux produits donc vous voyez il
y a tous ces codes où je trouve dingue
alors effectivement attention la pub de
toute façon tous les messages
publicitaires c'est de la manipulation
on vient chercher des petits messages
subliminaux pour venir vous pousser à
l'achat et vous donner envie mais ça ça
me touche mon secteur vous voyez on est
dans le mobile et je trouve ça malin et
une fois de plus la référence du produit
a aucun moment elle est prononcée
galaxie Netflix 4 à aucun moment on se
dit tiens tu as vu j'ai acheté mon
nouveau Galaxy S8 4 déjà les gens ils
comprendrais pas il reviendraient pas il
saurait pas Samsung voilà bref je trouve
ça extrêmement malin c'est pas ce que
vous en pensez vous est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres choses que que j'ai pas vu que
vous avez repéré vous dans cette pub
dites le moi dans les commentaires ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec mon analyse
ce que vous pensez effectivement que
Samsung c'est un peu compliqué de lutter
quoi dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en
bas est-ce que vous avez un Samsung qui
se plie ou pas et est-ce une fois que
vous avez regardé cette pub ça vous a
donné envie de craquer ou pas et est-ce
que vous avez envie de vous sentirez
épanoui avec vos smartphones de Samsung
le moins en bas dans les commentaires et
dites-moi si ce format vous intéresse
que je viens de défendre analyser un peu
des pubs de marque tech comme ça aussi
de comprendre et décoder les messages
dites-moi tout ça en bas dans les
commentaires nous on se retrouve très
vite pour continuer bien évidemment à
parler tech Samsung et de tous les
autres embrasse pour les soin de vous à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]